joining us now Senate Judiciary
Committee chairman Lindsey Graham first
of all your overall overall reaction
it's very hard I guess everything for
the next 237 days Lindsey is going to be
viewed through the prism of politics in
her presidential election that is the
nature of politics this should be
something that's not political but it
has been politicized let's be honest no
president ever acted faster president
was criticized for the travel ban
criticized for the quarantine criticized
no matter what he did on this particular
thing immediately gave us eight point
three billion dollars set up the task
force I gave a rundown timeline of all
things and he's still getting hit well
if you want to play the criticism game
almost every Democrat came out hard
against President Trump when he shut
down travel from China the probably
strongest decision he's made the most
important decision was to act early when
he saw what was happening in China but
the president said tonight this is about
us as a nation not me as a president not
my party it's about all of us so he gave
an economic vaccine if we will follow
his lead I'm not so sure about the
payroll tax yet but everything else he
said made sense to me to stabilize the
economy and prevent the spread of the
virus I think the president was
incredibly presidential tonight he was
reassuring he's doing everything he can
in my view to stop the spread of the
virus we're taking it serious but we're
not gonna go crazy all right let's go
through what the president's been saying
tonight he'll always put the well-being
in the American people first if we are
vigilant we will significantly impede
the transmission of the virus no nation
is better prepared than the US all we
are all in this together put politics
aside which would be good for once you
put the travel ban to Europe for 30 days
with the exception of the UK emergency
actions providing financial relief for
businesses directly impacted I guess the
the cruise industry the airline industry
and workers by the way hourly paid
workers so they won't lose their jobs
and they'll have some financial relief
if they have to stay out for caution
anything else he should be doing in your
view
I can't really think of anything I know
this if President Obama had given this
same speech they would be applauding all
over the country for decisive leadership
clear-eyed view of the problem taking
action preventive action trying to bring
about economic stability before it gets
worse
trying to prevent the spread of the
virus I hope that everybody listening
tonight saw a president who was in
command of the issue in charge ready to
do whatever's necessary to stabilize the
economy and protect the American people
and I would just say this of all the
economies in the world were the
strongest and of all the places in the
world to provide quality health care
America is the premiere spot on the
planet and we're going to stay that way
let's talk about a there is a need for
some perspective I've been trying to
give it for example in a year with
12,000 Americans with h1n1 this is
2009-10 this isn't about politics what
I'm saying here but 12,000 Americans
died 20,000 contracted the disease there
was never a travel ban there was never
any type of quarantine put in place
there was not this level of alarmism
even the markets didn't react this
particular way I've never seen a
president instinctively put a ban in
place take a lot of heat for it
why if the flu is my pure numbers much
more dangerous why do you think there's
this reaction that we see everywhere
which we should take it and we ought to
take everything seriously I want to cure
for cancer and heart disease for the flu
for a common cold and for a corona of
course we've got to be careful I think
the exotic nature of it it came out of
China it came from left field nobody
really understands exactly what it's all
about yet a coronavirus case is like an
airplane crash the flu is like a car
wreck we have a lot of car wrecks people
down car wrecks but it doesn't get much
coverage every time somebody gets
infected with a car on reverse it's like
an airplane crash and that's just the
way the media has treated this they
treat the coronavirus like a series of
airplane crashes and all I can say about
the president if you've got a better
idea come forward and what I hope he
will do is not sign off of some
democratic package coming out of the
house
else tomorrow that's not going to grow
the economy but will grow the size of
the government we don't need economic
stimulus for the federal government we
need economic stimulus for the federal
offer for the for the American people
and they're going to want to grow
government and what the president wants
to do is help the economy well and I
think this is an important thing now the
president's right I mean bringing all
these bankers and Wall Street guys in I
think is a private-sector repo they were
it listen we have had the greatest
economic growth we've had we see the
jittery markets reacting day by day to
what is going on here there's the added
factor of a oil battle if you will
between Russia and the Saudis and OPEC
that does not help things but at the end
of the day we've had an unprecedented
economic growth now the question is if
we can keep these numbers low local
cities local states municipalities doing
their things schools closing as they
deem necessary people take in the
precautions they can take at the end of
the day what we have is a virus that's
very scary like every other virus but it
is unlike h1n1 H that impacted younger
people this seems to really be impacting
or putting it real risk only the elderly
with underlying health issues and some
type of immune disorders how do you
interpret that data well what what I
understand is that this is targeted to
the people who suffer the most or older
people people pre-existing conditions so
I don't think we've had anybody in the
world die under 30 let's take it serious
but the president is meeting with the
private sector he's asking banks to be
involved he wants to increase the amount
of money the Small Business
Administration can loan to people to get
back on their feet look and see what
Democrats do tomorrow I think they're
going to grow government programs they
haven't talked to anybody in the private
sector about what we can do to stabilize
the economy their reaction unfortunately
is going to go going to be to grow the
government the president's action is try
to create a partnership between the
government in the private sector to
stabilize the economy and he realized
more than anybody any president in my
life
that the strength of the American
economy and American people is in the
private sector not our government
all right Senator Lindsey Graham thank
you tonight